hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar rt lamp best practices and tips
to accelerate detection of viral
pathogens including sars cove 2.
i am marie stone of labruts and i'll be
your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by thermo fisher scientific
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
in addition to submitting questions we
encourage you to participate in today's
webinar by answering poll questions
dispersed throughout the presentation
when the poll question is displayed
please select your answer by clicking on
your screen your participation is
greatly appreciated
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
i'd like to now welcome our speakers
ingrid vendelay r d manager for
molecular and synthetic biology thermo
fisher scientific
and leanne burrow r d scientist
molecular biology
thermo fisher scientific
ingrid and leanne you may now begin your
presentation
hello everyone my name is ingrida and
i'd like to start by welcoming everyone
again to this webinar focused on rt
lamp today we will start with a brief
technical introduction to rtlam as a
method and then share advice on how to
set up your workspace when working with
this highly sensitive technique
we would also cover a lump primer design
recommendations and share a simple
practical example of primer validation
process
we will also demonstrate how to generate
a synthetic rna control which could be
used to validate your reverse
transcription lamp results
and finally we'll finish by sharing
practical rt lamp solutions for
sarskovich research and surveillance
lamp stands for loop-mediated isothermal
amplification it is a fast simple and
specific dna amplification technique
under isothermal conditions
dna polymerase used in mum has a strong
strand displacement activity meaning
that amplification of dna can occur at a
single temperature because there is no
need for a denation step to separate dna
strands
when rna is used as a template a reverse
transcriptase can be incorporated into
the reaction to convert rna into copied
dna
briefly lamp uses 46 primers as
demonstrated on the right
amplification is initiated by a strand
invasion of an inner primer and
subsequent synthesis of an inner
sequence
the inner primal also contains a
complementary sequence and following
annealing of an outer primer which
displaces the first product the
complementary sequence allows the
formation of a self-hybridizing loop at
the end
and this form dumbbell structure then
serves as a seed for subsequent
exponential lamp amplification it has
multiple sites now for amplification
initiation
the end products are very long which are
also connected by single-stranded loop
regions into long catamers or often also
called cauliflower-like structures
the main lab advantages are related to
simplicity and flexibility
since it is an isothermal technique no
thermal cycler is required and only a
heating block is sufficient
it offers a fast turnaround time from 15
to 30 minutes or even shorter sometimes
and also multiple detection solutions
from real time analysis to endpoint
detection
it is a simple workflow with only a few
steps and as mentioned if rna is the
target simply incorporating reverse
transcriptase is enough
and all these features make lamp
compatible for use in low resource or
in-field settings
when choosing to use lamp it's really
important to pay attention for a proper
primer design
in order to control for a false positive
signal and hopefully today will provide
you good recommendations and insight on
how to do that
so now you should see the first ball
question on your display and i'd like to
encourage everyone to participate
i'd like to provide some recommendations
to help prepare your workspace in order
to avoid false positive signals since
mentioned before
and when preparing bulk lamp experiments
or simply handling a large number of
samples during your assay development
there's always the risk of workspace
contamination and
resulting false positive signal so
general guidelines for working in the
lab apply such as wearing a clean
laboratory coat or gloves while
performing experiments washing your
hands prior to working in the lab and
changing gloves frequently during the
experiment um especially after cleaning
your workspace such as laminar flow hood
or prior to adding your um no template
controls or negative control samples
always follow the recommended cleaning
instructions prior and to after each
experiment as provided in the protocol
or user guide and just generally follow
with laboratory practice guidelines
but when looking at lamp related
guidelines i'd like to specifically
highlight that using separate workspace
areas for rt lamp reaction preparation
and amplification from rt lamp amplicon
analysis by endpoint detection when
post-reaction tube opening is required
is specifically important to avoid a
false positive signal
discard usd agents if you suspect a
carry-over contamination and replace
with fresh ones
aliquot your reagents into working stock
volumes such as solid cutting primers or
your
rna dna targets or internal controls is
good practice and always use filtered
pipette tips and of course change your
pipettes between your technical replicas
so if you're preparing lamp reaction to
detect a dna target we recommend to
clean your lab space within vitrogen dna
zap crdna degradation solution to remove
any potential
contamination uh applicants from your
surroundings
and then clean your workspace with the
dna ion is free distilled water to
remove residual solution
and contaminate your workspace with a 70
ethanol solution however if your target
is an rna
sample then also clean with your uh in
glittergen rna zap rna is the
contamination solution to remove any
potential rnases that could degrade your
rna target and then remove the residual
solution with a 70 ethanol solution
however the most important
recommendation is really to not open
tubes or wells after
lamp amplification in the reaction setup
space to prevent amplicons spreading on
the workspaces and contaminating causing
a false positive signal in your new
reactions
also seal your no template control tubes
or wells prior to adding a target rna or
dna
and if contamination is observed also
consider using a different primer system
targeting potentially another genome
region
as well prepare negative controls in a
separate area to avoid a false positive
signal
and
also multiple technical replicates are
always recommended for your samples and
for your controls to properly validate
your reaction outcome
and here's a simple example of a
workspace when
multiple reactions are being set up so
here we're looking at the laminar flow
hood which contains cool racks to store
your reagents as well as your reaction
mix if there is temperature sensitive
and
graphs
are worn and filter tips are used during
the preparation of multiple technical
replicas
contamination can be recognized easily
when real-time detection method is
selected to either screen multiple timer
sets or to observe your reaction
kinetics
and in such case a mild curve profile
can be examined
and usually a specific amplification
produces a sharp narrow peak and here
it's highlighted in red
to also demonstrate that your technical
replicates overlay to each other showing
a specific amplicon however non-specific
amplification can be identified by
observing double peaks or wide shoulders
or even a shift in the melt temperature
by more than one degree if endpoint
detection is chosen
please have multiple negative controls
as indicated here in the orange color
tubes
and observing a single color change
which would indicate a false positive
separating it from the rest of your
technical replicates gives a good idea
that this is potentially a
cross-contaminated reaction mix
just checking it on an agarose
electrophoresis gel you can observe a
blur pattern and background which
indicates a false positive potentially
resulting from a carryover contamination
in the reaction mix
as mentioned lime primers
are crucial for successful lump
amplification and here are some
guidelines on how to successfully design
primers
lamp employs four to six primers binding
six distant regions of the target dna
and even though reaction can be set up
using four primers so inner and outer
primers addition of the two loop primers
significantly speeds up amplification
inner primers are hair conforming
primers that hybridize to the
complementary and reverse complementary
target sequences
which forms the dumbbell-like structure
and leads to the auto-cycling lamp
the target sequence is also important in
successful lamp assay design and if
faced with high sequence variation from
strange strain and aiming to detect
multiple strains
select conserved regions across chains
and variants to avoid false negative
results or also avoid conserved genes
from closely related organisms to avoid
a false positive result and blast can be
used to check for non-specific targets
select homologous regions across chains
to detect multiple related strains and
if aiming to detect multiple strains you
can also use multiple primer sets or
degenerate primers
key considerations for successful primer
design are very similar to general pcr
primer rules so gc content needs to be
monitored and limited
as well as the melting temperature of
the primers is important and lamp is
usually carried out at 65 degrees so
that should also be
the melting temperature
with your primer design it is important
that primers do not form secondary
structures especially for the inner
primer which is longer and forms the
tumble structure and to prevent the
formation of primer dimers it is also
important to ensure that the three ends
are not complementary
avoid runs of three or more of one base
or the nucleotide repeats and if
restriction enzyme sites exist in the
target sequence outside the primary
regions they can be used to confirm the
amplified product in such case you would
see a single band on the gel instead of
a signature lamp a ladder-like pattern
check distances between target regions
as provided here and also monitor here
with melting temperature
here i'd like to present an online tool
for land primer design which is the most
popular free tool to design primers
since it's cited in the majority of
literature it's called primer explorer
it has been developed by lamp and
vendors and the link is provided here on
the slide
it has a very descriptive informative
user guide and manual which really
provides a lot of useful information how
to design successful primer sets
um it has some limitations it's limited
by 2000 base pair target sequence it
supports only 80cg characters and
doesn't handle multi-sequence alignment
representation with generate nucleotides
which is often a problem when trying to
design book primers so we suggest not to
use the generated nucleotides
it's limited to a single execution
process and the output is in the html
format but despite this it's an
excellent tool
it's used very frequently and cited in
literature which really indicates that
primers work well
and as mentioned it has a very
descriptive user guide for more
information
so now i'd like to present a very
simplified primer validation process
example and here we're looking at the
target of synthetic measles rna and
primers here are either custom designed
using the tool that i just presented or
taken from published literature and the
materials for lamp
were in nitrogen superscript for rt lamp
master mix in nitrogen cyto9 green
fluorescent nucleic acid stain for
real-time detection to observe reaction
kinetics
and of course hplc purified primers with
the concentrations described at the
bottom left corner
so at the top we're looking at
primers from publications and at the
bottom custom designed and what we are
looking at in the lamb kinetic profile
is fast reaction speed we want to have a
fast
lamp
outcome
we want to see good reproducibility
between technical replicates so they
should overlay each other despite their
rna copy input
and we want to have a wide long
specificity window between specific
amplification and non-specific
amplification start which is indicated
by green curves so if looking at
publication primers
at the left we have a speed of just 10
minutes um technical replicates are very
reproducible specificity window is about
35 minutes allowing for a fast um and
specific
reaction
and then on the right we have
non-specific amplification overlaying
your specific curves um reproducibility
is not great and technical replicates
are spread out and we would have
difficulties and separating a false
positive signal from a specific
amplification here
at the bottom custom design primers are
compared and even though they are custom
designed they do not show equal
performance so on the right design a
even though it hasn't shown on specific
signal that reproducibility is poor
variability is high technical replicates
are spread out from 10 to 20 minutes
while on the left we have a speed of
just five minutes techno replicates
overlay each other its specificity of
window is the longest about 40 minutes
so both publication a primer set and
custom design b
show good performance as we would like
to have and here
we selected simply custom design b
because of the speed it's a faster speed
but both show a good performance and
could be used and hopefully this example
provides you information on what to look
for when examining a lum kinetic profile
and finally i'd like to present
on how to design a positive control for
your rt lamp outcome validation
so using positive and negative controls
is recommended to validate rt lamp
reaction outcome and when considering
your negative controls there are several
several options
so a no template control where a
reaction mix with water instead of a
target can be used a negative clinical
sample when we know that a target is not
present in the sample
a sample with another causative agent so
for instance if
aiming to detect measles
influenza could be used to make sure
that your primaries do not bind
non-specifically to another causative
agent or universal human rna sample
if human clinical samples are being used
there is a likelihood of background
ironies being present and this is also
good negative control
and for positive controls um they can be
either made in-house or purchased
commercially and if choosing to
make your rna control in-house there are
two possible workflows and the most
frequently used is cloning into
expression plasmid target dna
and then
linearizing purification description
steps can take several days so today i'd
like to present an alternative workflow
which only takes a few hours and uses
jane r string's dna fragments
so synthesizing rna using general
strings dna fragments can shorten your
workflow significantly and here we're
looking at
three gene strings uh that we used
um to produce our internal rnas
um double standard dna strings contain
t7 rna polymerase promoter upstream and
also had restriction size
sites added on both ends just in case
downstream cloning application is
planned but they are optional and
absolutely not required
and such chain strings can be used for
in vitro transcription reactions without
the need for cloning directly into the
transcription reaction which shortens
your workflow significantly gene strings
are supplied highly pure which again
helps to ensure your transcriptional
yields are great which is important and
simplified workflow to generate high
quality yields of synthetic rna
fragments within only a few hours is
presented so instead of these you can
have your rna much quicker
and here are steps so reaction setup is
about 15 minutes only and rna synthesis
using thermoscientific transcript 87
high yield transcription kit is about
two hours and then purification using
the in vitrogen mega clear transcription
cleanup kit is about 20 minutes and on
the right you can see the amount of
synthetic rna that was generated
following just these three simple steps
at the bottom we have electro serograms
of synthesized rna fragments we can see
sharp
peaks of our target rna of expected size
with three different strings that were
used
in our reactions
and here positive controls for rt lamp
are validated so first transcribed rna
was quantified where real time rtq pcr
here i'm only presenting um gene string
c
and you can see the copy number that was
calculated from rtq pcr results many
copies were generated directly from just
one microgram of custom dna gene strings
and a real-time rt lamp using cyto9
green fluorescent nucleic acid stain
demonstrated that rna transcribed from
gene string c
demonstrated equal performance to
commercial control or purified clinical
rna
and the
time to result was just 5.8 minutes when
commercial control was just 5.2 and we
have two good examples of clinical
samples with high or low at any copy
number and the reaction
time was very similar
you should now see the second poll
question on your display and your
participation is greatly appreciated
i'd like to now pass to my colleague
leanne to present rt lamp solutions for
star school d2 research and surveillance
thank you agrita and hello everyone my
name is leanne and i'll be presenting
the last portion of our webinar we're
focused on rt lamp solutions specific
for sars kobe 2 research and
surveillance
sars kovi 2's emergence spread and
health outcomes have impacted all of our
lives perhaps one of the most important
lessons we learned however is the need
for accurate sensitive and available
molecular testing solutions for
infectious disease
displayed here is a snapshot of the
united states centers for disease
control and prevention's timeline of the
appearance and response for sars kobe 2.
in february 2020 only three months after
the first pneumonic cases were reported
the u.s and many other nations
identified the immediate need for widely
available molecular tests
today mass vaccination has been possible
in the americas europe australia and
many parts of asia however molecular
testing remains critical for
unvaccinated groups including within
emerging nations for young children for
whom the vaccine is not available and
within vaccine hesitant populations
furthermore with the evolution of viral
variants molecular testing provides us
with epidemiological data on the
incidence distribution and impact of
vaccination on sars kovi to derive
pneumonia
let's discuss the sars kobe 2 virus in
greater detail
severe acute respiratory syndrome
coronavirus 2 or sars cov2 is a positive
sense single-stranded rna virus this
virus attaches to host cells using its
eponymous crown-like spike proteins
in the diagram on the left the viral rna
is shown in red and these spike proteins
are shown in orange
sars cov2 molecular tests detect either
this rna or spike protein
srs cobi2 infections continue to spread
novel variants have evolved these
variants of interest have small rna
changes in the s gene resulting in amino
acid changes in the spike protein these
changes may either help the viral
variants exhibit better host cell
attachment increased transmission or
viral load or improve the ability of the
virus to evade the host antibodies
with so much research and development on
sars kobe 2 it can be a challenge to
understand and relate all the
information that's been given to us
here we're outlining two of the most
common
attributes first sars cov2 test types as
well as the required sample types
sars cov2 is principally
a lower respiratory disease however
viruses may be detected in minimally
invasive sample types like saliva
nesopharyngeal swabs and nasal swaps
additionally the human immune response
to the virus may be observed using a
blood sample type
shown on the right there are three
common types of sars cov2 testing
nucleic acid based antigen based and
antibody test
nucleic acid based test detects sars
kobe 2 rna this is colored in red
these tests may be called pcr or qpcr
tests and are very sensitive and
specific
most nucleic acid testing requires
trained scientists and a centralized
laboratory to determine if the virus is
present therefore these tests often take
hours to days to perform and may be
expensive
alternatively antigen-based tests or
rapid tests detect sars-cov2 proteins
these tests may be performed at the
point of care without extensive training
or specialized instrumentation
these type of tests can tell a patient
whether or not source cov2 is present at
very high levels only therefore this
fast inexpensive test will identify
those patients that are likely
contagious
finally antibody tests detect the human
immune response to sars cov2 exposure
these tests can inform a patient on
whether they recently had or have an
infection
and the results are typically provided
with a quick turnaround time and little
financial investment
in addition to this common sars cov2
test we just discussed
rt lamp may be used for sars research
and surveillance
on the left we're depicting sars kovi 2
viral low variation where a person on
the extreme left in yellow only has a
low viral load this low viral load may
be detected with qpcr tests only because
these tests have high sensitivity
on the right the person in red has an
extremely high viral load this high high
viral load may be detected by any test
including the antigen tests which have
the lowest sensitivity
rt lamp based tests for sars cov2 are
uniquely positioned as they're nearly as
sensitive as the qpcr tests and are
nearly as fast as the antigen tests
the application of rt lamp is so well
suited for cyrus kobe 2 that the
landscape of this approach has
drastically shifted over the last two
years
as seen on the right of the slide in
2019 only about two percent of rt lamp
publications were focused on sars kobe
2. however in 2020 this metric
drastically shifted with approximately
60 of all lamp publications focused on
soros kobe 2 research available
thermo fisher scientific is invested in
providing rt lamp based solutions for
infectious disease detection including
sars-kobe 2 research and surveillance in
the last year ingrid's team and my team
have been focused on two specific
offerings the first is the in vitrogen
superscript 4 rt lamp master mix this is
an optimized enzymatic master mix
resulting in outstanding rt lamp
performance
a master mix provides the ultimate
flexibility allowing the user to select
their pathogen of interest their target
and their readout method
the second solution is the in vitrogen
colorimetric ready lamp kit this is an
off the shelf complete kit for sars kobe
2 detection in saliva or np or nasal
swabs
two reaction controls and two workflows
optimized for sample types are included
as with the superscript 4
rtlampmastermix the colormetric
readylamp is intended for ru only
applications with minimal cost or
instruments investments required
okay now i'm going to focus on the sars
kobe 2 research using just the complete
kit
the colormetric readylampkit provides
two workflows one for rna samples and
one for crude samples
in the case of rna sample type the user
collects saliva nasal or nasopharyngeal
swabs
sars kobe 2 rna is isolated from these
samples and then finally the isolated
rna is used in the color metric ready
lamp kit as sample input
here the user assembles an rt lamp
reaction
incubates at 65 degrees for 30 minutes
and then interprets whether the saliva
or swab sample type contain sars kobe 2
based on color metric change
samples lacking stars kobe 2 will remain
purple in color while stars containing
while samples containing stars cov2 will
turn from purple to blue color
for the crude sample types this exact
protocol is used with the rna isolation
step emitted
sars cov2 from these samples is
inactivated and lysed and directly added
to the colorimetric readylamp assay
here we've added a poll question we're
wondering what type of sample is best
for you and your research
let's look at some of the sars cov2
detection data with a color metric ready
lamp kit
for rna samples these are shown on the
left the complete workflow including rna
isolation was used
96 saliva and 96 np samples were
processed where half of each sample type
contained the sars cov2 virus
the rt lamp reactions containing 100
copies of sars cov2 from both samples
all turned the indus from the initial
purple color to the positive blue color
demonstrating positive overall reaction
while all reactions lacking sars kobe 2
remained purple in color
for the crude samples types that are
shown on the right the workflow omitting
rna isolation was implemented
in this case all rt lamp reactions
containing 250 copies of sars cov2
turned blue
while reactions lacking sars kobe 2
remain the initial purple color
overall with both sample types superior
performance in terms of rt lamp accuracy
and specificity are recorded
one critical question about the color
metric ready lamp kit is
does the rt lamp reaction detect sars
cov2 variants
sars cov2 variants have a key rna change
in the s gene but don't have concomitant
changes in other regions of the genome
the colormetric readylamp primers don't
target the s gene and therefore should
capture all viral variants of concern
in fact when we investigated more than
633 000 deposited sars kobe 2 genomes
more than 98 are perfectly complementary
to the kit primers
furthermore we purchased 15 available
sars kobe 2 variants
for all 15 the colormetric ready lamp
kit detected the presence of a virus at
50 copies per rt lamp reaction
supporting that this kit does detect
sars kovi 2 variants
finally we demonstrate that the color
metric ready lamp kit is specific for
sars cov2 and does not suffer from false
positives in the presence of other
respiratory pathogens
we tested isolated nucleic acid from 12
saliva donors containing either flu a
a pooled respiratory panel sars cov2 or
no pathogen
the respiratory panels tested herein are
pooled aliquots of 8 to 10 causative
agents of respiratory disease as you can
see only rt lamp reactions that
contained 100 copies of sars kobe 2
turned from purple to blue and thus are
called positive reactions
while all other rt lamp reactions
remained purple in color and are
negative
this data fully supports the specificity
of the color metric ready lamp kit for
detecting sars cov2 and differentiating
between different types of respiratory
disease
we hope you now have a better
understanding of how rt lamp may
accelerate detection of viral pathogens
including sars kobe 2.
today we provided a theoretical
introduction to vamp technology and
practical information on rt lamp
workspaces primer design and validation
and synthesizing rna controls
furthermore we described the thermo
fisher scientific rt lamp solutions for
research and surveillance
[Music]
here we have an additional poll question
focused on rt lamp applications we'd
appreciate your feedback
thank you so much for your attention
today and greed and i would love to
address any additional questions
and look forward to that in the q and a
session at the end
we have one additional poll about
learning more about rt lamp solutions
thank you ingrid and leanne for your
informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar if you have a question
you'd like to ask please do so now just
click on the ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen we'll
answer as many of your questions as we
have time for
let's get started our first question is
can you use unpurified or minimally
processed samples with the rt lamp
master mix
hi thanks for the question so in
vitrogen superscript for rt lamp master
mix was developed using purified rna
samples
however the bst dna polymerase which is
included in this product
is described in literature to
demonstrate improved processivity and
good inhibitor tolerance so we highly
recommend trying and optimizing
techniques for direct lamb described in
literature with this product and
hopefully we'll have some
recommendations soon as
well thank you
our next question is
what method do you use to quantitatively
record the color change with the
calorimetric ready lamp kit
so the color metric ready lamp kit can
be read with a naked eye just
monitoring that purple to blue color
transition however we understand that
some people may want a more quantitative
measurement
so to address this need we have
application notes available on our
website
for using the color metric ready lamp
kit with a spectrophotometer or a plate
reader
so this should help users who want to
not only use a quantitative measurement
using the instrument but also anyone who
is interested in high throughput
applications
so
the color metric ready lamp kit
application notes can be found at
www.thermofisher.comreadylamp
thank you
next question when analyzing crude
samples with the colorimetric ready lamp
kit
how is the sars cov2 virus inactivated
in the samples
right that's a great question we also
want to note that being very careful
with how you handle the sars cov2 virus
is paramount for any research
so here what we're suggesting is that
the user inactivate the sarsko v2
virus and lyse it using a combination of
a 95 degree heat step
in the presence of a reducing agent the
colormetric readylamp user guide has
this protocol incorporated it only adds
five minutes to your overall workflow
and it can help you and your lab be
safer and be less exposed to the virus
great thank you
next question
what rna isolation kits are compatible
with rt lamp solutions from thermo
fisher
so another great question um so for the
color metric ready lamps kit
specifically we've tested a variety of
commercially available rna isolation
kits and they all work great
we've done the most work validating the
magnetic bead-based magmax kits as well
as the column-based pure link kits and
those are really
great for superior overall rna isolation
thank you
next question
how can i distinguish specific
amplification from non-specific
thanks that's a very important question
so as mentioned lump is highly sensitive
and produces amplicons in a form of
concatomers or cauliflower-like
structures
that wear in size but contain repeats of
the same dna target sequence
so such amplicons usually have a unique
melting temperature which
can be used to confirm amplification of
a specific target
and when using real-time detection
option a melt curve analysis can
demonstrate the naturation profile and
help separate specific amplicons from
non-specific
so specific complicants should
demonstrate a single sharp dissociation
peak and characteristics that indicate
um non-specific amplicons are wide
shoulders multiple peaks the shift in
melting temperature
when compared to specific amplicons that
could be
one degree or more and hope that helps
thank you
looks like we have time for one more
question
what downstream applications are
compatible with rt lamp amplicon's post
reaction
okay that's another great question so
lamb produces amplicons that vary in
length
and are composed of numerous repeats of
the short sequence as mentioned before
so they form these long cauliflower-like
structures and such products are not
typically suitable for downstream
applications
so if the restriction enzyme sites are
added on the target sequence except the
prime regions then they can be used to
confirm unique amplicons via restriction
and gel electrophoresis
well thank you ingrid and leanne
for your presentation
do you have any final comments for our
audience
just want to thank everyone again for
joining in and hopefully this was useful
and you'll be tempted to try rt lampson
yes i just like to repeat and greet us
thank you to everyone at thermo fisher
especially our team members for
contributing to all our rt lamp
solutions and we really look forward to
working on this more especially with new
applications
well thank you again ingrid and leanne
for your time today
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor thermo fisher scientific
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye